three-time Super Bowl champion Pro
Football Hall of Famer and top analyst
in the business for Fox Sports Troy
Aikman here on the Rich Eisen show how
you doing Troy hey rich I'm doing great
thank you yeah thanks for thanks for
being here and thanks for joining I mean
we did that rehearsal yesterday was that
it was quite some time I mean but I
don't know how much rehearsing you two
with Joe Buck so they don't do near that
much no I know we did all that but I'd
love to I'd love to delve in a little
bit of the stuff that you said during
that that that that mock session that
I'm sure you're gonna repeat on Thursday
night as well who do you think is the
the quarterback with the best
opportunity obviously it depends on the
marriage that's gonna happen on Thursday
night who get that you get drafted by
but just sheer skills wise who do you
think has the skillset to succeed best
in the NFL well the guy who who I have
is the number one quarterback of Sam
carnold and I just think rich that he
checks most of the boxes I will tell you
though with that being said that you
know in talking with a general manager
former general manager that I think a
lot of in his belief a franchise
quarterback if you view one as a
franchise quarterback then that
quarterback cannot have any minuses and
all of these quarterbacks have at least
one - and so with that I think it's safe
to say that for a lot of people they
don't think any of these guys are
franchise quarterbacks and I'm not so
sure any of them are either but it just
tells you that we're in a starved League
in teams you know the draft is about
measurables and hope and those teams
that don't have a quarterback they want
to come out of this draft with the fan
base that has hope and and some of these
teams are going to come away with that
now whether or not any of these
quarterbacks go on to have great success
is anybody's guess history would say
that half of them are not going to be
very good but I think Sam darn old when
you look at the safest pick and I don't
always think the safest pick is the
right pick but if if I were Cleveland I
think Sam Donald is the guy based on
their history that they should go after
so I mean how is it possible and I and I
and I fully admittedly ask you this
question Troy as somebody who's been
talking about this draft pretty much
every day for months and and and by
months I also mean last year when we
were talking at the draft last year in
Philadelphia that this year would be the
year
in which there would be tons of
franchise quarterbacks available how is
it possible that we're now here and that
there would be some talent evaluators
including yourself that think that there
might not be any franchise quarterbacks
in this year well I hate rich every year
every year there is a best quarterback
in the draft and and so every year but
that doesn't mean that there's a
franchise quarterback but that's easy
for me as I sit here in my chair in my
office and say that but if you're a
general manager and you don't have a
quarterback it's hard to pass up on a
guy who who is the best or who you think
is the best in this case there's there's
more than just one particular guy but
we've seen we've seen over the years I
don't want to name names but we've seen
guys who have gone early in the draft or
at least have been first-round picks and
once they get into the NFL you're left
kind of scratching your head you're
saying really what was what was it that
they liked and and again III wish all
these guys the best of luck I hope they
all go on and have Hall of Fame careers
I you know I I know how hard the
position is but the history would say
that that's not going to be the case and
I don't want to say that people last
year overvalued these guys I think Sam
Donald for instance was a guy who could
come off a really great freshman year
redshirt freshman year and then you know
wasn't quite as good this past year so
all of a sudden people start putting
holes in it and you know some of the
others I think they have their own
reasons as to why maybe they wouldn't be
projected quite as high if they were in
a different draft I dunno you know this
draft because if sheer numbers has been
compared to a lesser extent to the draft
class of 83 and of course we have
hindsight now and know what a lot of
those guys did but I don't think there
any negatives when people looked at John
Elway and thought whether or not he was
gonna be a great player well there were
three first ballot Hall of Famers in
that dress right well when it all shook
out I mean here on the Rich Eisen show
first ballot hall-of-famer in his own
right out of UCLA so what what is your
relationship with Josh Rosen it's good I
had an opportunity to to get to know him
after his freshman year there at UCLA I
watched him throw that same summer I
came away watching him rich and I said
this guy's is natural of a guy throwing
the football as anyone I've been around
and and that hasn't changed in my
opinion I think he's terrific I think it
I think durability is a concern I think
when you have more the concussions you
had the shoulder injury but but when
you've had head injuries in college
coming into the NFL where the hits I can
tell you are a lot tougher that that is
a concern but but also along with that
is is is he coachable and I think if you
eliminated those things and maybe
durability being the biggest one if you
were able to eliminate I think he's
hands-down the the best passer in this
league and for those that would say well
he's not real mobile well Peyton Manning
wasn't real mobile either and my guess
is if a paid man you were in this draft
you'd still go number one and and I
think just on pure ability to throw the
football and most Pro ready
I think Rosen's the best in the bunch
then you obviously had some Oklahoma
roots as well before UCLA what's your
sense on Baker Mayfield and I like a lot
you know I will say that watching him in
college I got real worn out just every
time the camera was on him that he was
talking or yelling at some opponent or
whatever it was and and then I really
studied him on tape and and I think the
guy can really play he's the most
productive of the group he's accurate
with the football he's got plenty of arm
strength and and I believe that he is I
think he has the skills that translate
to the NFL the height I know is a
concern and I know you can't point to
many people many quarterbacks under six
one that have had success but I have
always felt I felt this when Doug Flutie
was coming out in the NFL Draft I
thought height at the time was overrated
I've continued to think that and even at
six four there were times I couldn't see
receivers because of the offensive
lineman that were in front of me and
it's about throwing through windows and
he's been able to do that he's been
highly successful doing it III really I
think he and Rose are the two guys of
the guys I've seen are the only two that
I think can step into a pro team a play
on week one troy aikman here on the Rich
Eisen show what about Josh Allen the
questions of his accuracy knowing as you
do about the transition from one level
to the other and obviously losing two
before you can win Troy what what can
you tell me about Josh Allen's accuracy
issues that
give you pause well I you know when we
first preface the answer by saying with
Sam darn old he's had problems
protecting the football and I believe
that with tough coaching and good
coaching you can coach a lot of that out
of a quarterback I believe when it comes
to accuracy yeah I know they've worked
on tightening up his throwing motion and
his stride and some of the things as
mechanics and some of the things that
that maybe lead to some inaccuracies but
in my experience in watching
quarterbacks you you can either put the
ball where you want to put it or you
can't and some of the throws that he
missed some of them are intermediate
throws I would say that that he didn't
have very good protection and he didn't
have really good receivers so sometimes
it's on the receiver not being where
he's supposed to be or not making the
catch I saw a number of drops but when
you start missing little flare throws
and and flat routes and swing routes and
check downs when you're when you're air
melon those guys on those throws that's
when I really became alerted and I don't
know that that will change he's been a
56% passer throughout his career and III
don't envision that being a whole lot
different at the next level all right
before I let you go Troy because I know
you've got an event here in the in the
Metroplex area and then more studying
and prep for tomorrow night why do you
think Dez Bryant finally got some
walking papers from Jerry Jones can you
break that down for me you know it's a
really good question I I know for the
longest time whenever someone questions
something about Dez the the answer you
know out of Valley Ranch and and from
the Cowboys was that hey no you
misunderstood he's very passionate and
and then to not even offer him a pay cut
which is something originally I was told
he would not take then I've learned that
he he would have been willing to listen
and yet they didn't even offer that and
now they've already come out and said
that they have no interest in resigning
him so I think it you know sometimes
there's a lot that happens behind closed
doors that were not always knowledgeable
about and it just kind of sounds like he
had finally kind of worn out his welcome
and with whatever the lack of a
connection was between he and dak
Prescott the lack of production
certainly and what they were paying him
they couldn't bring him back at the
number that he was getting paid but to
not even allow him an opportunity to
take a pay cut or the possibility of
resigning him I think it just says that
this goes way beyond you know what he
has done or what he's capable of doing
on the football field
what do you mean by Garrett guys though
I mean that that was the one thing that
I that gave me pause when I heard what
he said to Jane Slater on the NFL
Network that Garrett guys well I will
say there's always I don't know to
answer that I know Jason Garrett is a
friend of mine I have not spoken to him
since since Dez was released I'm not
exactly sure you know what that means
although I do know that having been in
locker rooms there are players that are
perceived you know like there's teachers
pets or whatever there are players who
are perceived as hey you know they'll
beat the drum for this coach or this
coat you know they're all in on this
particular coach I to be honest with you
in my conversations with Dez Bryant and
certainly my conversations with Jason
Garrett over the years I would have I
would have guessed that Dez Bryant was
it was a Garrett guy so you know when he
made those comments I was a little
surprised by that I think a lot of
people were I know Jason Witten was
offended by that I think that locker
room is I think it's been a very
close-knit group and they were all very
protective of Dez over the years and I
think they were all a little stunned and
and I don't say they're hurt they're big
boys but I don't think they like the way
that he walked out and and maybe through
some of them under the bus
Troy really appreciate the time as
always great seeing you yesterday really
look forward to working with you chat
with a bond be great all right Troy
thanks to the call you got that straight
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience